it's kind of unimaginable not believing
in them
my grandmother had an elf friend in the
rock has come to me in my dreams I'm
convinced else to exist
[Music]
I'm professor of folkloristic to the
University of Iceland one of the areas
of research that I've been working on is
so-called elves or olive art along with
who to [ __ ] the hidden ones that
Icelanders are so interested in I can
picture some kind of idea of a hidden
person kind of looks like a human they a
little bit old-fashioned clothing they
have their own Society emotions and
feelings they are born grow old and I
think they live in rocks they can't show
themselves if they choose to but rarely
do but you never know when it will
happen you have maybe ten percent say
that they don't believe and then those
who say they do believe is begin about
ten percent but in between you have all
of the rest who may be possibly probably
who knows we can't say no you can't say
no it's not that they believe they are
worried that it might be something there
when it comes down to it though you're
not going to mess with
my name is Peter Masterson and I'm head
of communication resi as a DeGroat
administration so this is the rock that
we'd moved from the place of mr. roat
days and we moved it over here people
thought that this might be an amateur
and these people asked us if we could
maybe move the rock we will look into it
not because we believe so much in else
at the wrote administration we look at
it as part of our cultural inheritance
[Music]
we know the people in the Viking times
were buried in mounds which showed above
the earth as each generation goes by the
living memory of the people within the
ground turns into a much more hazy idea
about beings that live out of sight the
nature of Iceland makes you feel really
strong emotions a nation where your
house can be destroyed by something you
can't see we naturally try to explain
these things by means of personifying
the the environment and everyone is
surrounded by nature you see the
mountains you see the ocean everywhere
the belief started because of the strong
connection that we still have I think
there is a pressure from the society as
a whole that we are the people who
believe in elves and we should tell
everybody that because we have been
trying to get more tourists for a long
time I think a lot of people will say
they believe in elves but in heart they
don't
if you couldn't have moved it we would
have Mastodon it's just a rock
[Music]
whether you believe it or not these
stories about the elves and these
creatures they teach us to respect
nature and the else here are for the
most part I think respected should the
law consider the hunter for maybe not
but I think maybe the law should try to
consider what the right matric in half
because it doesn't really have a voice
even though it's quite outdated maybe
giving nature a voice there are people
coming from countries who've in a sense
lost this connection this magic in
Iceland you can talk about the elves and
these are the world to everybody and
people will not lock you up
it makes Iceland different and they
likely been different to other nations
in all ways we wanted to be like this it
would be a nicer place to live if they
were hidden people there what do you
think
you